[Music]
so let's say you're a cyber criminal
theoretically of course
maybe you're the kind of cyber criminal
that posts these annoying comments
pretending to be youtubers to get people
to send you money
maybe you're making money selling stuff
on these silk road style dark net
markets
or maybe those cyber crimes are too
basic too plebeian for you
you want even bigger paydays so you turn
to ransomware where you as a hacker
inject crippling viruses into businesses
computers
shutting them down in exchange for
getting paid a hefty ransom whatever
cyber criminal you are
if you're not making money right now you
suck because business has been booming
if you're not a successful entrepreneur
right now in the easiest time to be a
successful entrepreneur because there's
so much money in the system and the
internet is at scale
you suck the problem with any type of
ill-gotten gains is that if you just
straight up use that money to buy a
lambo to buy that mansion
eventually not immediately but
eventually people like the irs the fbi
the dea
are gonna come knocking on your door
wondering where you got all this money
from
so we need a way to clean this dirty
money so that it looks like it came from
a legitimate
source like you got the money from a
legal business you own or something
back in the old days where you made all
your blood money in fiat there were a
lot of proven ways to launder that money
like buying a cash heavy business like a
restaurant or bar and slowly injecting
that dirty cash into the business to
make it look like your customers gave
you that money
today however we have technology
[Music]
and the payment of choice for all you
cyber criminals crypto with the bulk of
crimes being paid in bitcoin
now this may sound amazing right crypto
is anonymous decentralized not
controlled by the government all you
need is an internet connection to
launder money now
but in actuality as many cyber criminals
have come to find
using bitcoin to launder money is a
terrible idea as one hacker group called
darkseid recently found out
may 7 2021 hacker group darkseid takes
down the largest fuel pipeline in the
u.s
crippling the east coast's fuel supply
through a single compromise password
that didn't have two-factor
authentication turned on
and just before 5am a ransom note
appears on one of colonial's computers
demanding 75 bitcoins
colonial pays that ransom and just one
month later the department of justice
announces that it was able to seize the
majority of that ransom back
colonial paid the hackers in bitcoin
which is supposed to operate
outside the control of any government
but the fbi was still able to retrieve
it
not only was the fbi able to trace the
transactions back to the wallet
containing those bitcoins but they were
also able to get their hands on the
private key for that wallet to get the
money back
how they were able to get that private
key remains a mystery that's why some
people are saying that bitcoin is the
greatest thing to ever happen to the fbi
i think what people need to recognize is
that bitcoin is the greatest thing to
happen to the fbi
it's an extremely useful technology and
bitcoin is
quite literally the best form of of
ransom payment for
federal agents unlike cash where it's
very hard to trace or bank transfers
where every transaction is at least not
public with bitcoin every transaction
from start to finish is all nice and
tidy on the blockchain for authorities
to scrutinize
the only thing anonymous about it is
that you can't tell who owns which
bitcoin address but all it takes is for
the fbi to get a subpoena for your
internet records or your email records
to tie a transaction back to you
so if you're gonna make dirty crypto you
better have a way to erase the trail
back to you
this is the new age of money laundering
an ever evolving game of cat and mouse
between cyber criminals and cops
and some of the methods they use may be
shocking for educational purposes only
[Music]
now even if you're not a cyber criminal
you should still be taking your online
privacy very seriously
for you filthy men out there protecting
your privacy is kind of like washing
your hands after you use the restroom
a lot of you don't do it i would know
because i witness it in public restrooms
all the time and it's absolutely
disgusting
sure you're not gonna catch a disease
every single time you don't wash your
hands
but you should anyways sure your bank
account isn't going to get hacked every
single time you use the wi-fi at
starbucks or the airport
but you should be on a vpn anyways
having a vpn is just good digital
hygiene
and that's where private internet access
comes in the world's leading vpn
provider at a fraction of the cost of
other vpns and today's video sponsor
they're one of the best reviewed and
highest rated vpn services in existence
they have a strict no logs policy so
even they can't see your data
it's available on all devices and
operating systems they've got over 10
000 blazing fast servers in 70 plus
countries with unlimited bandwidth
plus with only one private internet
access accounts you can connect however
many devices you want and use up to 10
of them at the same time
and you also get to watch restricted
movies on netflix search for a movie you
want on a website like unogs.com
for example the godfather see what
countries that movie is available in
connect to one of those countries in the
vpn and boom
and you get all of this for just two
dollars and eight cents a month plus two
months free when you choose the
three-year plan
and they have a risk-free 30-day
money-back guarantee and you can even
pay in bitcoin or crypto if you want
so stop what you're doing pause the
video and go to
privateinternetaccess.com jaketrain with
the link below to claim this offer right
now
that's privateinternetaccess.comtrain
with the link below
back in the early days of crypto it was
the golden age of money laundering
you get your dirty crypto from whatever
racket you were running and then you
simply deposit that crypto into an
exchange and withdraw cash blockchain
analytics firm elliptic estimates that
major exchanges help cash out between 60
to 80
of illicit bitcoin transactions today
however it's a lot harder regulators are
putting more and more pressure on
exchanges so a lot of exchanges have no
your customer or kyc rules
and they even work hand in hand with
authorities to stop money laundering
that's where over-the-counter or otc
brokers come in if you're a big crypto
whale or institutional trader that needs
to sell a ton of crypto at once
placing a giant order might not get
filled immediately the order might be
broken up into smaller pieces at
different prices
because there's not many people wanting
to buy 10 million worth of crypto at
once
so they go to otc brokers who match them
up with a buyer at a predetermined
negotiated price
which makes otc's crucial for the
liquidity of the crypto market and otcs
might make up the majority of all crypto
transactions
otcs work within popular crypto
exchanges like binance and huby
but because otcs have much lower know
your customer kyc rules they make for a
great tool to launder our dirty crypto
with some otc brokers seemingly
specializing in helping cyber criminals
launder crypto
here's a simplified version of how it
works you put your dirty crypto into an
intermediary wallet you agree on a set
exchange rate to convert your crypto
into cash with the dirty otc of your
choice
you send your crypto fund that wallet to
the otc and the otcs work their magic
and shuffle the funds around with other
clients money and other otcs
and then the otc goes to an exchange
like binance or huby to get your cash
hydra is the largest dark net
marketplace today with the russian silk
road site accounting for 75
of all illegal transactions and one of
the things you can buy on there are
treasure men
treasure men are an interesting service
that has popped up recently you send
them your dirty crypto and they will
literally leave bundles of cash
somewhere for you to pick up
they'll bury it underground or hide it
in a bush and they'll tell you the
coordinates for a fee of course
how much can you trust a stranger to
send them your crypto so they can bury
it somewhere instead of just taking off
with your money
i don't know but hydra has plenty of
other ways to cash out of your crypto as
well
including exchanging it for gift cards
prepaid debit cards and so on april 27
2021 u.s federal agents arrested roman
sterling golf owner of a 336 million
legal crypto company called bitcoin fog
for unlicensed money transmission and
money laundering what is bitcoin fog
it's known as a bitcoin mixer or crypto
tumbler and it's exactly what it sounds
like
think of it as a literal laundry machine
for your crypto you and a bunch of other
customers deposit your crypto into the
tumbler all your coins get mixed
together and you get your deposit back
in multiple random increments over a
random period of time
this way it makes tracking exact coins
extremely hard for cryptos with public
ledgers like bitcoin
the tumbler in exchange takes a small
percentage usually one to three percent
bitcoin fog took in around 336 million
in bitcoin over his lifespan which comes
out to around a 5 million
profit for the owner and tumblers are so
widespread that apparently 13
of all bitcoin addresses are tainted
with silkworth coins even if they never
went to the sites
instead of mixing bitcoins you can also
get our public cryptos entirely and
exchange it for privacy coins
privacy coins are like any other crypto
except while they provide more privacy
they make sure you stay anonymous and
keep things like your wallet addresses
and transaction balances a secret but
which privacy coins offer the best
protection
monero not only is monero one of the
most popular privacy coins around
they're also completely untraceable
which are the words every discerning
cyber criminal loves to hear
monero is the cryptocurrency of choice
for many of the world's best ransomware
hackers
like rival a globally feared ransomware
group that no longer asks for money in
bitcoin only monero
once you've received your untraceable
monero you can always trade it for clean
bitcoin on any major exchange that
access monero completing the laundry
cycle leaving you free to blow your
money on whatever you like
z cash is another top choice for
laundering z cash uses something called
zero knowledge proof
basically this allows the transaction to
be completed without ever recording any
information about the people involved or
how much crypto was sent
remember the less anyone knows about
your dirty money the lower the chance
there is that you'll ever get caught
and last on the list of the best privacy
coins to launder your spoils is grin
an open source cryptocurrency network
allowing developers around the world to
add to its security and secrecy features
grin also runs a signature privacy
feature called mimblewimble which allows
past transaction data to be deleted from
the blockchain without compromising the
security of network
you should be warned though these
privacy coins may not be around forever
crypto fraud fighting companies like
cyphertrace are actively trying to ruin
a good thing by developing and trying to
patent tech that would trace privacy
coins like monero which could mean an
end to one of the easiest safest ways to
launder money
i think the chances are pretty low
though
[Music]
the invention of bitcoin atms have also
changed the money laundering game
just like depositing money at a regular
atm you can now walk up to any bitcoin
atm and deposit as much money as you
would like into a completely anonymous
crypto wallet
which means you don't need a bank card
and you don't have to enter any true
personal information to turn cash into
crypto this is great if you're still
running any traditional rackets where
your profits are still in fiat you take
the dirty money and you simply use one
of the 11
000 unregulated bitcoin atms around the
world to turn that cash into clean
bitcoin
and then you can turn that bitcoin into
other coins like privacy coins
eventually redrive for claim ready to
spend cash via the techniques we talked
about earlier etc
[Music]
privacy wallets are responsible for
around 12 of all the bitcoin laundering
last year
making them the preferred choice among
cyber criminals they work a lot like
tumblers or mixers with added security
measures like anonymous ip addresses and
encryption
instead of pulling your money with
hundreds of other bitcoin users you add
your dirty crypto to a single
transaction with a few
others and receive the exact same amount
out except that is unlinkable and
untraceable to your activities
one of the most popular platforms around
wasabi wallets has the benefit of being
completely trustless
meaning that no one can steal your money
which they would have regretted anyways
if you're an old-school criminal and
prefer keeping a classic touch on your
crypto laundering activities you may
appreciate the simpler method
when you steal a car that car is
considered hot so you keep it tucked
away until people stop looking for it
and then you take it out for a spin
crypto is the same way when you first
make your dirty crypto it's hot so
instead of using all these complicated
exchanges and platforms simply dump your
dirty crypto into a code storage wallet
leave it there for potential years at a
time while the search for the money
cools down
then one day when you're sure no one's
looking for you anymore take your score
out of storage and you're good the only
downside to this method is that you have
to wait
and of course there's no way of knowing
if some die hard investigator will still
be looking or not
crypto has been bittersweet as far as
money laundering goes on one hand it's
still being done mostly in bitcoin as
far as anyone can tell so all the
transactions are public which allows for
people to run heavy complex data
analysis on the transactions that could
have never been done with fiat
on the other hand cyber criminals are
coming up with new methods and tools for
outwitting cops by the day
and although it's estimated that less
than one percent of all bitcoin
transactions are from illicit activities
it's hard to tell how big it really is
it's hard to tell which transactions are
legitimate and which aren't
after all how many scammers on youtube
are leaving comments asking people to
send money via western union anymore
none of them it's all being done in
crypto and as with any problem comes
great business opportunities
one of those companies analyzing crypto
data is chain analysis and they're the
ones that wrote an incredible crypto
crime report that was referenced a lot
in this video
this video isn't sponsored by them but
it was just so readable and thorough
that i wanted to give them a shout out
and i'll link to them below
i agree with me kevin in that this space
is probably going to continue exploding
in the coming years
as this financial crimes cat and mouse
game continues it is a space that
i'm actually getting more and more
interested in investing in
i think there's gonna be a really big
market going forward
for investigating crypto crime and
there are companies who it has been a
while since we've done a crime video so
let me know what you guys think of this
one in the comments below and if you are
new to this channel and this one
interests you you will definitely like
the original video we did on money
laundering where we go over the
traditional money laundering methods
with fiat that video is almost at a
million views i'm really proud of it and
you can check it out with the link below
and you know what else you can check out
with the link below our sponsor private
internet access for all your online
protection needs
a great vpn at a great price with the
link below private internet access dot
com
jake tripp one of the next videos we
have coming up is the rise and the fall
of the silk road and the guy behind it
ross albert crazy story that you're not
gonna hear anywhere else on the news so
it's gonna be really good and while
you're down there you might as well
click that red button to subscribe
because we make videos like this every
single week on the most provocative
stuff in the world of business from
crime to power to money to geopolitics
all the above
you can follow me on instagram at
jtrend.io for more behind the scenes
stuff than the life kind of stuff
and that is gonna wrap it up for this
video thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome i've been jake
you know what to do stay dangerous out
there and i will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
you